MARIA: WELCOME BACK.
MY NEXT GUEST LED NEW YORK CITY
THROUGH ITS DARKEST DAYS
FOLLOWING 9/11 EARNING HIM THE
NICK NAME AMERICA’S MAYOR,
18 YEARS LATER THE BIG APPLE HAS
BECOME THE EPICENTER OF THE
CORONAVIRUS EPIDEMIC WITH
THOUSANDS OF NEW CASES EVERY DAY
IS THE CITY PREPARED FOR THE
VIRUS TO PEAK IN NEXT
TWO WEEK, JOINING ME RIGHT NOW
IS FORMER NEW YORK MAYOR RUDY
GIULIANI.
AND MR. MAYOR, IT’S ALWAYS A
PLEASURE TO SEE YOU THANK YOU
FOR BEING HERE.
>> PLEASURE TO BE WITH YOU,
MARIA YOU’RE DOING A GREAT JOB
OF COVERING THIS TERRIBLE CRISIS
MARIA: THANK YOU, SO MUCH.
I KNOW THAT YOU WERE IN NEW YORK
THIS WEEK, YOU TOURED NEW YORK
CITY, BROOKLYN, OTHER AREAS,
WHAT WAS YOUR ASSESSMENT?
>> WELL, I SPENT ABOUT THREE OR
FOUR HOURS IN THE CAR YESTERDAY
I DROVE ALL THROUGH MANHATTAN
AND THEN WENT ALL THE WAY OUT TO
CONEY ISLAND AND TOOK SOME
PICTURES, TRIED TO SEE , YOU
KNOW, ARE PEOPLE COMPLYING?
THE ANSWER IS BY AND LARGE YES,
BUT THERE ARE SOME PEOPLE THAT
ARE NOT EITHER NOT WEARING MASKS
OR  TOO CLOSE TOGETHER YES, BUT
IT’S A MINIMUM.
IT DEFINITELY IS A MINIMUM SO IF
YOU ASK ME IS THE CITY PREPARED?
I WOULD SAY THE PEOPLE OF THE
CITY ARE EMOTIONALLY
PREPARED.
I THINK THE PRESIDENT, THE
GOVERNOR, AND NOW EVEN THE
MAYOR, THEY’VE ALL DONE A
GOOD JOB OF GETTING THE PEOPLE
READY FOR WHAT IS GOING TO BE,
THEY SAY, A TERRIBLE NOW ABOUT A
WEEK AND A HALF.
IT COINSIDES INTERESTINGLY WITH
THE PASSOVER, WITH GOOD FRIDAY,
AND EASTER, ALL VERY VERY SOLEMN
RELIGIOUS HOLIDAYS.
PASSOVER IS ABOUT THE ANGEL OF
DEATH PASSING OVER YOU PRAYING
FOR IT.
I THINK PEOPLE ARE SITTING AT
HOME PRAYING FOR THAT, SO I
THINK WE’RE PREPARED.
ARE WE PREPARED WITH SUPPLIES,
WITH THE NUMBER OF SUPPLIES, WHO
KNOWS?
I MEAN, REMEMBER, BEFORE WE GET
TOO HARD ON ANYBODY, NOBODY
EVER KNEW THIS EXISTED FOUR
MONTHS AGO, RIGHT?
THIS IS NOVEL CORONAVIRUS.
NOVEL MEANS NEW.
IT’S A TOTALLY DIFFERENT STRAIN.
IT ACTS DIFFERENTLY.
BUT I THINK WE’VE MADE A LOT OF
PROGRESS MEDICALLY WITH IT.
WE HAVE MEDICINES NOW THAT CAN
AT LEAST DEAL WITH THE SYMPTOMS
AND SOME OF THEM HAVE BECOME
POLITICIZED WHICH IS A SHAME.
IT’S REALLY JUST A SHAME.
MARIA: I JUST SPOKE WITH DR.
STEPHEN HAHN THE
COMMISSIONER OF THE FDA AND
HE TALKED ABOUT THE VACCINE,
TALKED ABOUT WORKING WITH HYDRO
CHLOROQUINE.
YOU THINK THAT WE SHOULD BE
USING HYDROCHLOROQUINE?
>> I THINK WE SHOULD LET
DOCTORS DECIDE WHETHER WE SHOULD
USE HYDROCHLOROQUINE, NOT THE
NATIONAL BUREAUCRACY.
THIS DISEASE CAN KILL YOU, AND
IF HYDROCHLOROQUINE HAS SIDE
EFFECTS, NONE OF WHICH ARE DEATH
BY THE WAY, THEN THOSE SIDE
EFFECTS I MAY WANT TO ENDURE
BECAUSE OF THE RISK OF DEATH AND
IT MAY BE DIFFERENT IF I’M 25 OR
IF I’M 75.
THOSE CHOICES SHOULD BE GIVEN TO
DOCTORS, NOT TO THE BUREAUCRATS
IN WASHINGTON, WHO WANT TO GO
THROUGH THREE BLIND TESTS.
WHEN WE FINISH THE THREE BLIND
TESTS, YOU KNOW, MOST OF AMERICA
COULD BE GONE AND THEY SIT THERE
IN AN IVORY TOWER, WHEREAS  THE
GUY SITTING AT
MOUNT SINAI HOSPITAL WITH A
PERSON WALKING IN WHOSE 65 YEARS
OLD WITH 104 TEMPERATURE, AND I
SENT ONE THERE JUST THE OTHER
DAY, FIRST THING THEY DID BEFORE
THEY EVEN TALK TO THEM IS GIVE
THEM HYDROCHLOROQUINE AND IT’S
BANNED IN NEW YORK BY THE
GOVERNOR.
WHY IS THE GOVERNOR BANNING IT?
EVERYTHING SHOWS THAT IT WORKS.
EVERYTHING SHOWS THAT ITS SIDE
EFFECTS DON’T BOTHER YOU UNTIL
YOU TAKE IT FOR A MONTH OR  TWO,
FOR CHRONIC ILLNESS LIKE
RHEUMATOID ARTHRITIS OR  LUPUS,
SO FAR NO SIDE EFFECTS AND THE
STATISTICS IN FRANCE WHERE
THEY ALLOWED IT WERE EXCEPTIONAL
LY GOOD.
MARIA: YEAH.
THERE’S A DISPUTE OF WHETHER IT